- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan.
My one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves
and I want some of that
to rub off onto you
so that you can take
that thing that's in here
and unleash it into the world
so to help you on your journey,
today we're continuing the
How Billionaires Think,
Success Advice from the
Top Series, Volume Four,
and as always guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you
make sure to put it in quotes
and leave it in the comments below.
It will inspire other people,
but as you write it down
it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
- Every time's a perfect
time to start a business.
There's no bad time.
If you do the work, if
you do the preparation,
you'll know when it's time
and it doesn't mean that it
won't be a little bit scary
but, you know, you'll know,
and you don't have to quit the daytime job
if you don't feel all that comfortable
and you can give it a run at night,
but whatever works for you.
Now with the internet,
you've got all the choices in the world
and you can just go out
there and do your own thing
and set up a business part time.
- We've had this tradition
for, I don't know,
probably seven or eight
years at the company
where every week we have a Q and A
where our employees can
come and ask me any question
that they want about what's going on
and what the direction of the company is
or questions or things that
they read about in the press
or that their friends
that use the product,
what they're asking them,
and it's been this really
important tradition for us,
both because we really believe
in openness and communication
and that's kind of what
Facebook is all about,
but it's also really important for me
and for running the company
to be able to get feedback
and to be able to learn
what's on people's minds,
what our employees and folks
who are part of our team
are thinking about, and a lot of the time
there are good questions that people ask
that change the way that we
think about what we're building
and what we're here to do in the world
that often make us go think and reevaluate
how we should be approaching
different problems.
- There's a very thin dividing line
between success and failure
when you start a business from scratch,
and if you don't have enough
money to pay the bills
you go the wrong side
of that dividing line
and if you can somehow get
enough money to pay the bills
you stay the right side
of that dividing line.
I've always been running
faster than perhaps I should
and I have great difficulty
saying no to things
so I keep on taking new things
and we've just managed
to stay the right side
of the dividing line over
the last 50 years in business
but equally in those early days
when you're starting a business
without any financial backing,
it's easy to slip the wrong side
and in fact, most entrepreneurs
do slip the wrong side
and the important thing is
then just pick yourself up
and start again.
If it doesn't work at that time,
keep going until you do
succeed and not to give up.
- I have young filmmakers
come up to me and say
give me some advice for doing this,
and I say don't put
limitations on yourself.
Other people will do that for you.
Don't do it to yourself.
Don't bet against yourself and take risks.
NASA has this phrase that they like,
failure is not an option, but
failure has to be an option
in art and in exploration
because it's a leap of faith
and no important endeavor
that required innovation
was done without risk.
You have to be willing
to take those risks.
So, that's the thought
I would leave you with
is in whatever you're
doing, failure is an option
but fear is not.
- There's the Latin expression
which I think is great.
I love it, was in the now very old movie
called The Dead Poet's Society,
but the line of the movie was
carpe diem, seize the day.
The opportunities are there,
but you got to reach out and pick 'em up.
You got to grab at 'em.
Some of you may have
already done that at the U,
in your classes, in other
students that you met,
in your extracurricular
activities, but grab them.
Don't be afraid to make a mistake,
'cause you know what you can
do if you grab the wrong one?
Drop it and pick up another one.
It's okay.
Seize the day.
I think back of all of the luck,
but also the times that
were in front of me
to seize the day.
I don't know what got me to
drop out of business school
and come to Microsoft.
My parents thought I was a whack job.
Neither one of them graduated college
and they thought this
was really a wild idea.
I was lucky.
I seized the day.
Microsoft, one day some
guys fly in from IBM
and all of a sudden we figure
out we could actually provide
all the software they need
for this thing that became
the personal computer.
People, Bill, Paul, they had the wisdom
to seize the day when that
opportunity presented itself,
and yet when you think
of all the opportunities,
when I think back of all
the opportunities I've had,
the one that was most important
was an opportunity I got in 1969
sitting in my junior high school class.
I was in a public junior high,
not very stimulated at the
time and over the loudspeaker
they said a private
high school in our area
that I'd never heard of
was giving scholarship tests that weekend.
I told my mother I wanted to take them.
She said that's fine, as
long as you get a scholarship
because we can't afford to send you there,
but that's really where
I got switched out,
switched on in math,
switched on personally,
energized in a way that
never could be turned back
and I'm very thankful
for that opportunity.
Yes, there's a lot of luck in opportunity,
but there's a lot of seizing the day
and I encourage you all to
reach out and carpe diem,
really seize the opportunities
that are in front of you.
- I don't wish to alienate people here
with what I'm about to say, but you know,
your destiny is in your hands.
I succeeded because I had to.
No one sorted anything out for me.
I didn't ask out to any
government and said pretty please,
find me some work, please,
and do something for me,
because it was a waste of
bloody time, simply that,
a waste of time, and if I
was going to do something
I had to do it myself.
That's it, and I would say
to every one of you here
don't sit around relying upon
magically some government
going to create an environment
that's going to make it easy for you
to find work and find jobs.
You've got to go out there
and fight for it yourself.
I'm sorry to say I can't give
you any other form of advice.
If you want something
bad enough, you do it
and if you look at some of these wannabes
that make themselves
television stars and pop stars
and all that type of stuff,
they have a desire to want to be famous
and they don't stop until
they're recognized and they do,
and half the people you see
on television these days
in the entertainment industry
are those that had a
determination they wanted to do it
and I'll a little rider to that,
none of them can bloody sing.
Not helpful, right?
I mean, you didn't find
that helpful answer
but you're going to control your destiny.
I'm telling you.
No one else is going to do it,
not unless you got a rich dad.
Have you got a rich dad, a rich uncle?
No, well then that's it.
You're going to have to do it yourself.
- The funny thing is
with enough persistence,
most things that seem
impossible become possible.
I'm always amazed at how often
you can turn things around
and people take no for
an answer too easily.
It's whether you're
trying to achieve a goal
like get into business school,
or my Green Card was the same way.
I left a job that had sponsored me
but I still got my Green Card
even though no lawyer would take me.
I became my own lawyer, got
my Green Card without working
while I was in business school,
and I did it perfectly legally.
My strategy there was if I
could convince immigration
I'd confuse them and I did,
and they gave me my Green Card.
- Trust your gut.
It's so important to trust your gut.
I saw a man speak one time
and he said I'll prove
to you in four words
there's no such thing as a bad idea
and he said, "Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles."
So, I'm here today to
prove to you in two words
there's no such thing as a bad idea
and that's footless pantyhose.
So, no matter what your ideas are
you're doing something
better than your competitors.
That's why you're a business.
You've thought of an idea.
That's why you're here,
and then be prepared for the opportunity.
- When you go out into the world
you should try to stand
up against the trend
even though it might, literally,
it might cost your job,
it might cost your promotion,
but in the end think for yourself.
Be innovative.
Try.
I mean, I'm not telling you to go in
and tell 'em what to do.
You've got to be careful
about that obviously,
but if you have ideas, go slam the table.
Don't worry about it.
Come up with your own imagination.
- To be serious, if you
want to be the next thing
you have to have a very big heart.
You have to take quite a lot
of risk, calculated risk.
First of all, you have to
make sure that you are honest.
You have to make sure you
don't destroy the name
because your name is very important.
The most valuable asset
that you have going forward,
if you don't have a good
name, even the banks,
it doesn't matter how big you are
they're not going to touch you,
so you must make sure they
have a very, very good name
and number three, you
have to make sure that,
you see that look, nothing is impossible.
One you see that yes,
nothing is impossible,
it means that you can
actually achieve that target.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed the video.
I'd love to know what did you think of it?
What was the piece of advice
that you're going to take
some kind of immediate action on somehow
in your life or in your business?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.